let me talk briefly about cops fa okay
yesterday I told you about Donald
Trump's tweet in the morning where he
set Twitter ablaze with the word cops fa
the tweet of course being this despite
the negative press cobbs fa he deleted
the tweet in embarrassment we wondered
whether this was all part of donald
trump's mental and emotional regression
that sources close to him have been
describing
but what's almost even more concerning
is how long the tweet stayed up i
yesterday yesterday i misspoke on the
show and i said it stayed up a few
minutes it was actually a few hours
about how about hours that it stayed up
so yesterday at the White House press
briefing a reporter asked hero press
secretary Sean Spicer whether Americans
should be worried that the president is
staying up at all hours of the night
tweeting gibberish and Spicer responds
by saying that some people did know what
Donald Trump meant by cob buffet and the
room of reporters could not contain
their laughter take a look at this
hunter train to Shawn do you think
people should be concerned the president
is posted somewhat of an incoherent
tweet last night and the event stayed
off for hours no if I didn't stay up so
long there's no one watching us now I
think the the president in a small group
of people know exactly what he meant
like
what I would like you to say nervously
inflate on itself is a good pharmacist
at this point as you can hear the sound
in the room a mixture of laughter
disbelief and genuine curiosity people
saying oh wow what does cops have you
mean and Sean Spicer declining to answer
that I imagine that hey Sean should we
be concerned that the president is
tweeting gibberish in the middle of the
night
no I'm convinced no more questions Sean
you know this whole cost SI thing just
started out as a lighthearted story but
I think Sean Spicer's defense here is
very telling because if he's not willing
to own up to the administration or Trump
making a mistake in this instance was so
inconsequential he'll do it for any
instance as well absolutely that was
exactly my thought which is you could
just say oh it was a mistake it's just a
typo he met coverage news coverage and
that's it and we move on instead no
people knew what it was and it wasn't a
typo can anyone else hear in that clip
the disillusion and defeat in Sean
splicers voice he clearly seems worn
down like he can sort of barely take
this nonsense anymore every day he seems
more beaten yeah the poor guy honestly I
think he may be the next to go and
that's why you're not seeing him on
camera these days and you see said
what's her name Sara how they run how
can Vander's taking a bigger role yes
and that that I don't think there's a
there's any coincidence there may be
cops Fe was some sort of acronym like I
alluded to earlier in the show something
like come over Vladimir for an exciting
fraud evening or something like that
maybe we're just upset that we're not in
on it we're not in that small circle of
people who know what that means I know
it's one of those things where there's
it's almost authoritarian a sort of
dictatorial in nature where hey it's all
the masses that are the ones that aren't
privileged enough to understand what
cops FA is all you have to do is say it
was late made a typo no big deal next
question as I as I read it I thought to
myself is this the real real life or is
this just Cobb taffy which is a you know
I think a song lyric that some of our
older fans might remember I'm guessing
that one is not one of your wheels
Bohemian Rhapsody I know that
all right we got anyway talk to me on
Twitter I'm on Twitter at the Pakman
table ceci or cops taffy or however it
is that you pronounce it